and we start here at noon with that
breaking news metro police have
confirmed raiders player henry ruggs iii
accused in a fiery dui crash that killed
one person in spring valley happened
just after 3 30 this morning at rainbow
and spring valley parkway that's between
flamingo and tropicana our hector mejia
has been following this story all
morning long and he's joining us now
with the very latest here in the
afternoon hours as we continue to learn
more hector
yeah police still on the scene more than
eight hours after this happened the
aftermath still here visible
investigators around the vehicle right
now metro police say raiders wide
receiver henry ruggs iii was driving the
corvette that slammed into the back of a
toyota rav4 the rav4 caught fire killing
the person inside we've learned once
ruggs is out of the hospital police plan
to charge him with dui resulting in
death the 22 year old was rushed to
university medical center with
non-life-threatening injuries we have
video from earlier this morning the
crash leaving a debris scattered across
the northbound lanes of rainbow a
stretch between flamingo and tropicana
police say this all happened just after
3 30 this morning the first officers on
the scene found the toyota on fire and
the person inside dead right now the
coroner is on site working to remove
that body we don't know how fast they
were driving police say rugs did stay on
the scene and showed signs of impairment
meanwhile high profile attorney david
chestnut issued a written statement that
says in part quote on behalf of our
client henry ruggs we are conducting our
own investigation and ask everyone to
reserve judgment until all facts are
gathered meanwhile the road is still
closed right now again eight hours after
this crash first happened now police did
not immediately say whether there were
any passengers with rugs although the
associated press is reporting that there
was a female passenger in his vehicle
who was also hurt that's the latest on
the investigation reporting live hector
mejia live local now hector thank you
henry ruggs a rising star in the nfl and
a big part of the raiders offense this
year joe muller standing by university
medical center where ruggs was treated
this morning joe
there it's unclear if rogs is still here
at umc or transported to the detention
center we did just check the clark
county detention center website a short
time ago and it does not appear he's
been booked just yet but meanwhile we
are hearing from the raiders for the
first time here is a statement they
released just a short time ago it says
the raiders are aware of an accident
involving henry ruggs the third that
occurred this morning in las vegas we
are devastated by the loss of life and
our thoughts and prayers go out to the
victim's family we are in the process of
gathering information and will have no
further comment at this time 22 year old
ruggs is the raiders wide receiver he
was the first pick by the raiders and
12th overall pick in the 2020 nfl draft
he's originally from alabama and came to
las vegas after playing for the alabama
crimson tide where he won a national
championship in 2017. fans have been
reacting on social media many people
tweeting out other disappointment about
this crash and what happened this
morning and also a lot of people
expressing their concerns for the family
of the victim as well reporting live
outside of umc joe mohler live local now
a story